one of the core ideas of capital in the
twenty-first century is compactor tax
return on capital return on your right a
little bit neater return on capital and
comparing that and comparing that to
economic growth with the contention that
if the return on capital if R is greater
than G if R is greater than G then this
is associated with that this right over
here would be associated with rising
income equality and that more and more
income is going to go towards the owner
of owners of capital versus labor and
since capital tends to be concentrated
wealth is you know you could view
capital as wealth and since wealth tends
to be concentrated that'll just make the
concentration happen even further even
more inequalities in wealth now before
we get into that and whether that
whether you believe that causality or
not is let's just understand return on
capital and how that might compare to
economic growth and how that might
create returns to return income to the
owners of capital or income to labor and
Link this through let's just think of a
very very very simple economy let's say
the whole economy is nothing but a gold
mine so let's say this is year one right
over here and the whole value of the
economy all the wealth in the economy so
the capital in the economy let's say
that we just value it as a thousand gold
pieces and obviously we could go into
how you know how is that valued at
cetera cetera now that actually does
come into the conversation is you know
we're thinking about the market value of
things or we looking at some things on a
more intrinsic basis but let's just go
with this simple simple analogy right
now just just start to get our hands
around the idea our heads around the
ideas of return on capital and economic
growth and how they might relate to each
other
so the capital it's it's 1,000 gold
pieces I'll just write GP for short
1,000 1,000 gold pieces and let's say
that in that year the national income so
it's a gold mine so it's just producing
gold so let me do this in green so total
so the national income and the whole
nation is just a big gold mine national
income let's say it had it that we have
a national income of one hundred gold
pieces one hundred gold pieces and let's
say that that's divided between income
to labour you needed people to work on
the gold mine to actually mine things
and then whatever else and so that this
this one hundred gold pieces is going to
be split between the owners of the
capital the people who own the land and
the tools and whatever else of the gold
mine and the people doing the work the
labor so let's say that fifty of this
fifty gold pieces goes to labor so
that's the part that goes to labor and
let's say that fifty gold pieces goes to
goes to the owners of capital so I'll
just say it goes to capital and this is
let's say maybe there's no taxes in this
we're not going to go into taxes and
complicate things just yet so this is
the after-tax so we can now calculate
the return on capital R and year one R
is going to be equal to well the owners
of capital got fifty gold pieces
they got fifty gold pieces and the
capital that they employed was a
thousand gold pieces so 50 divided by a
thousand this is going to be this is
going to be five percent right over here
now let's think about this in the
context of economic growth let's say we
go from year one to year two so now
let's go to year to year two and we'll
just say for the sake of argument that
all of this capital that the owners of
the capital got that they reinvested it
back into the gold mine and so now the
value of the gold mine so the capital
now in year two is going to be one
thousand and fifty gold pieces the
thousand that we started with we
earned another 50 we're reinvesting that
back into the capital maybe we buy some
more equipment some more land whatever
it might be and so now it's 1,050 gold
pieces and let's say the next year the
national income grows so national income
once again we're saying this is a super
simplified economy overly simplified
arguably that's nothing but one big
goldmine and now let's say the national
income the national income grew by let's
say grew by 2% so the national income is
102 102 gold pieces now there's some
ways there's there's a bunch of ways
that we could split this but let's just
say for the sake of argument so well
let's just make it clear what we just
said we just said that our growth right
over here is 2% now the question that
and this is one of the central questions
of the book is just because R is greater
than G in this situation is that going
to lead to more of the national income
going to the owners of capital or is it
going to or or is it going to go the
other way around or is it going or is
the level of inequality going to stay
neutral and I encourage you to pause
this video right now and try to think
about that on your own given all of
these numbers come up with different
breakdowns of say year twos national
income breaking it down between how much
goes to labor and how much goes to
capital and think about in this
situation where R is going to G is it
always going to lead to more inequality
well it actually depends how you break
it down this year so you could
definitely have a situation where you
have potentially growing inequality so
for example you could have a situation
where still labor gets fifty gold pieces
fifty gold pieces while capital is
getting fifty to fifty two gold pieces
now the return on capital is going to be
52 divided by ten 50 52 divided by ten
fifty the amount of income to capital is
52 the value of the capital
1050 gold pieces and so we have return
on capital of four point almost 5% but a
little bit under 5% four point nine five
percent so in this scenario the return
on capital the return on capital is
approximately four point nine five
percent and you'ii see that once again R
is greater than G and inequality de
seems to be getting a little bit more
with the owners of the capital R getting
more of the income a larger percentage
they're getting more than 50 percent
than they saw before but you could have
things go the other way around you could
have things go the other way around
maybe labor had a little bit more
leverage this year and they were able to
negotiate some wage increases and so you
have fifty two gold pieces going to
labor and fifty going to capital now
what's the return on capital well in
this situation the return on capital is
going to be fifty so they're essentially
getting the same income but over a
larger investment over a larger capital
base over ten fifty which is equal to so
50 divided by ten fifty gets us to four
point four point seven six percent so
approximately four point seven six
percent approximately four point seven
six percent so just in this very I guess
you could say simplified analysis you
could see that just looking
superficially at R and comparing it
superficially to G from one year to the
next doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to have rising income
equality now it could be a proxy for it
it could be kind of a very high level
way of looking at things but just in
itself if someone told you in a year hey
are the return on capital is greater
than G you can't say for sure that that
in that year that in that in that year
that has gone by that there has been an
increase in inequality now what we will
do in the next few videos is to dig a
little bit deeper in that question and
use a little use some spreadsheets to
look at some scenarios look at scenarios
where
maybe we hold our constant or RNG
constant and see what happens to
inequality or maybe we hold inequality
constant and see what our has to trend
to and we'll do that in the next video